this morning we kick off a week of
coverage in our school matters series we
will focus on the mental and physical
health issues facing schools from nurse
shortages to the pressures of sports and
see how school staff are being trained
to tackle the opioid crisis today we
will see how an elementary school school
in rural Colorado is tackled tackling
bullying before it reaches the
playground the initiative is supported
by a three year state grant Barry
Petersen explains why you may be
surprised to learn where the grant money
comes from very good morning good
morning John when Colorado became the
first state to allow sales of
recreational marijuana in 2014 it meant
millions of dollars collected from sales
taxes and a lot of that money is
earmarked for education which is how a
small Colorado town of around 7,000
people got the money to start a program
that stops bullying in its tracks
good morning park new HAWX school day at
Parkview Elementary includes the usual
classes like reading and math it's not
allowed to play and the unusual classes
on bullying
Leslee treat role plays with her third
graders they're bullying a kid they're
saying to them that they can't play
they're not allowed to play we call that
exclusion okay she plays the bully 2/10
late Medina
tinleigh you need to get out of here we
told you we weren't playing with you
today and Andrus Varela knows how to
step in trying to invite her to play
with me why because she would have been
sad and I always liked making people
happy by being instructed of the exact
words then they have the ability to step
up and make a difference in this rural
Colorado School District these classes
are taught from kindergarten through
high school Aaron Jones is the principal
I think it means the world if kids don't
feel safe they're not gonna learn
they're not going to achieve the ring is
different in a small town it's not just
about what happens in a classroom right
here at recess
these kids will see each other all the
time all over the place we see each
other at the store a church rec league
sports after-school programs what the
more than hundred thousand dollar a year
anti-bullying program is funded by the
state from top sales taxes despite the
fact that they as permitted under
Colorado law do not allow marijuana
shops I never thought I would see the
day where marijuana money would would
fund programs in education did anybody
come up to you and say no no don't take
that money
no one's ever shared any concern about
that fact professionally if this grant
has really shown me that marijuana
dollars can be directly used for student
success in this case bully prevention
it's cut bullying incidents by 23% and
it's taught kids to think before they do
the wrong thing
gianni lopez is a fourth grader what
have you learned to help you stop never
considered being a bully but when I went
when I tried to stop myself I always
think am I saying the right things
something kinda missing something nice
for Parker Daniel bullying was real he
was a target moving here from Texas he
was picked on for having a different
accent one bully even threatened Jim one
boy who's gonna beat me up on the buzz
was that frightening then his friend
Chloe Fernandez stood up to the bully
Chloe used another tactic she learned as
part of the anti-bullying program
strength in numbers we go to the
bullying me tell him to stop or we're
gonna tell him and we're gonna stop it
by herself and what happened he never
touched or did anything to Parker again
also not scary like going to the bully
no because I had my other friends that
came with me too now because the other
students knew how to help Parkers bad
days are how do you feel now that they
your friends have stayed with you now I
feel like I fit in now I know I have a
lot of friends and will stick up for me
if I ever got bullied again I went to
junior and
your high school in US Montana town even
smaller than Lamar so I will understand
how people talk and word spreads that
someone is having trouble in school
oddly enough the person being picked on
can feel embarrassed like they did
something wrong which makes a program
like this a life changer for vulnerable
kids who now won't be victims of
bullying
I live on story berry because it's
making it show that it's so much cooler
to act the other way yeah and what a
good message to send to children listen
some adults could use this class to I
have to yeah
giving the kids the words yeah so they
know what to say and their kids you know
they're not born with this knowledge
instinctively
so what my friends with me yeah I have
my friends with me to stand up right so
he's good and then those kids will pass
it on yeah they will press it on and it
will be good for all of them that's
right all of us all of us